next up he says that the Forman Magnum
is oval in the elongated skulls where in
humans it is round the opening of the
Forman Magnum appears to be oval and not
round as it is in Homo sapiens sapiens
here we're looking at a normal human
skull and we're going to look underneath
at the fan Magnum which is this really
large hole here and if we look at the
elongated skull the first thing that we
notice really is that the elongated
skull has a smaller framan Magnum and
sure enough it's also but if you do a
quick search for the normal size and
shape variation of for randman Magnum
you find that different people have
different sized and different shape for
Rond Magnum this is just normal human
variation Brian's claim that it is not
is again false I'm beginning to notice a
pattern here I'm not sure if I'm the
only one but I'm noticing a pattern